[Music]
please last time you could grew a beard
you know I had one about two years ago
and I liked it I mean it's just but when
I went back to TV land and said like I
wanna do it your shows of the beard on
this city not a chance of him why not
consistency they want consistency
there's something called a Q rating
which measures how people are disturbed
by images they see it when they have
some familiarity with an image and it
changes it's not good for advertisers
and television is really at the end of
the day but advertising and it's what
sustains all of it and you really want
to make great television but you also
don't want to alienate or bite the hand
that feeds you you have to keep the
advertisers happy and that's sort of
what I've learned after doing this for
many many years there has to be some
consistency to both the performance and
the look which is how I got into this
whole idea of this uniform a black suit
with a white shirt type in which is
something that call from an old style in
the 30s and 40s on it back
they did it then to keep the tie in
place that does a great job tighten the
tie not never dress down as you can see
so now the black suit and we'll all kind
of take my vitamins and so into trying
to stay healthy I got a whole regiment
be see you made so crazy until at a time
I just noticed it looks like all the
prints in here is your photography yeah
it's all me the other thing that's
surprising is you don't run with a big
Posse no are you feel where's the money
that's no sense it's also slows you down
I mean you answer your own phone calls
you yeah I found the posse actually made
me less efficient I'm not kidding I
talked to Posse guys all the time look
at all those people are dragging around
that was an expensive that's inefficient
you're always dealing with someone
else's problem I got a great team I get
to help at the Home Office and I don't
care where they are as long as they get
their stuff done and that's how we work
24/7 you don't have to be in the office
but often they are because it's just a
better place to be we have a spectacular
office it's done like a guitar
collection in it
that's in Toronto well we've got a
couple of offices you know ones there
are going in Boston is that where I
started out
[Music]
to think about putting on this uniform
this now I'm gonna go do some television
and the key to TV I learned usually go
from the makeup girls is you don't want
a lot of stubble because it makes the
makeup look terrible and you have to
wear powder otherwise the skin has a
weird shine to it in 4k so but you don't
want to do too much powder otherwise you
look dead it's an art so first shave
then I've got a whole makeup kit that
travels with me and you do your own
makeup I've learned how to do it
the drills with Tommy otherwise you'd
have to have that's like the posse thing
you'd have to have a makeup artist with
you all the time so this is a I use Mac
because it's got a fantastic base to it
around the eyes for one set and then you
move to a studio powder like this for
the head I had a lot of real estate to
cover so you really should do this with
your jacket off because you get dust
alone but I'm running for time here how
can you get your hair cut I get it cut
almost every 10 days because I like it
really short and if I don't it look like
Bozo the Clown because it grows out on
the sides and I'm often getting a call
from Linda saying I'm watching on TV and
you look like bozo get a haircut she
said that to me yesterday when I was at
CNBC you ever think about going the full
Michael Jordan like yeah I tried it I
don't like it it looks to Daddy Warbucks
I don't look like mr. wonderful it's a
little trick I learned on Shark Tank ago
just getting the right height
it wasn't that gorgeous that looks
fantastic so now we're gonna start
matching watches pins we're gonna go
pick up the AP code 11:59 that is an
engine
imagine this watch and then after that
we're going to go to rubber B to modify
some watches for the shark tank shoot
next week you're taking a few of the
connectional with us time that's the one
thing you can't fax any performance if
you gotta keep the pace and that's not
easy so it's cool here let's go
[Music]
make sure everything's cool we're going
[Music]
we're on the road be there in about 20
minutes
what are we doing I just walk right in
[Music]
[Music]
okay I don't know if I need to get a
picture of the pan and the watch
together to send a wardrobe for approval
I don't know if you want to shoot that
this will you see this pan I don't want
to take away from the whole ap thing but
you got to see this pen it's quite
something you see I told those guys
listen to mr. wonderful the rose gold
and the red after all the headaches who
went through finding the right red all
around the world for those alligator
it's the right red and I think it's
gonna look fantastic so with so this
this watch with the right the right
writing instrument the right cufflinks
is going to be El supremo
I'm looking forward to it so anyways
look it's the only one in America you've
got it right there a lot of these
manufacturers don't have the vision of
modifying the band and so I have to do a
lot of head squeezing but pretty well I
get what I want by the time it's over I
mean I am the customer let's start there
plus I think it looks so great on
television including I mean this is a
what I like about a P is they actually
make conversion kits so this watch
you're seeing here right now will this
afternoon eventually have a red band on
it so it's and I'll be keeping this
bracelet which is priceless to I mean I
got to match these back and you never
know we'll end up with this watch an
inheritance story they may want the
original band with my son likes it or
not
and he's if he's a good son maybe
otherwise I'm like a feral I'm taking
them all with me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
subscribe to my channel you know what
happens you'll be dead to me
[Music]